let's go to the phones at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47
50 and see what's on people's minds
let's start with our caller from the 7 8
6 area code caller from 7 8 6 who are
you where you calling from it's me that
is you all right my name is Christian
I'm a student from Florida hey Christian
what's going on so I just wanted to ask
you what because I've had this idea
recently that I think the United States
should move maybe for more direct
democracy okay so like I just want to
see what do you think would be the best
mechanism to achieve that because I had
I just gonna throw an idea out there you
can tell me what you think about it yeah
imagine someone for example like Bernie
Sanders becomes president and he passes
an executive order that allows a law or
maybe a constitutional amendment to be
achieved by a direct national popular
vote yeah how do you think that's
possible
do you think that's something that's
like someone should strive for listen
there are a number of different ways
that our democracy could become more
direct one of them as you're suggesting
is replacing the electoral college with
a national popular vote that's a good
idea the other thing you have to
consider is that when corporations and
rich people have disproportionate
amounts of power and their desires are
far more likely to become law or policy
than those of someone in the middle
class or the lower middle class or
whatever that is a form of making
democracy more indirect by which it is
not an issue of the number of people
that want something but more an issue of
the economic power that they hold so yes
I think there are a number of ways that
we can make our democracy more direct
I've been talking about some of them for
a while and I think it's really great
that you're thinking about it Christian
but there's something very strange
happening on your phone that sounds like
crinkling paper so I'm gonna let you go
because it's a little bit painful to
hear but I appreciate the call and a
very very important topic